lucas giolito goes to the hill in search
of his second win as era is a little
higher than he would like but a lot of
strikeouts and innings pitched
condolario the switch hitter who was two
for four last night two and two coming
that's a fastball and it's a full-size
strike 3-1 gone to jacoby jones
upstairs fooled him anyway back-to-back
strikeouts for lucas giolito
rivera first pitch swinging the other
way for nomar mazzara
an efficient first inning for lucas
giolito and today's starting pitcher for
the tigers is spencer turnbull his fifth
start of the season he had a little
hiccup little road bump last time out
he's really had a good start to his
summer if you take away that one three
balls in a strike base is loaded
one down turnbull
edwin takes ball four he missed his spot
and it's a bases loaded walk
one nothing sucks in the first and it's
not over yet it's nomar mazara the
left-hander two and two
mazara left side
and they get one
and the sox will get a run so two
nothing your score mazara drives in one
on the bouncing ball
and the sox will trade and out for a run
to mccann
right center field that flies to the
alleyway down for another hit
sox get one more run
masara to third it's three nothing socks
the former tiger piles on
normally when he gets through the first
without a whole lot of problems it sets
up the rest of his day the jonathan
scope
he struck him out right back to the
fastball in the attic
and one gone in the second one on one
out kristen stewart
to first abraham spins return pass to
first nicely done
sleek double play by the sox infield
second game of the series for maven
he went around for sure strike three won
gone
you see the good rotation coming off the
last three fingers of his hand it goes
straight down and maven is out that's
strikeout number four
oh and two on willy castro
he got a swing in the mid strike three
of fastball is where you mentioned the
no-hitter and then the jinx comes in or
are you gonna not even say that today
it's worth thinking about especially
because you have not
said it
oh boy
this is on you buddy tim
did he get him no save the call at first
i think you knew what you were doing
there yeah i had a feeling on that one
two on nobody out and miguel cabrera
there's a wave and a miss and it is
strike three so one gone and a big first
out for the sox nico goodruck he's been
a very patient man with the bases loaded
swinging a miss strike three he waited
around and still
got bamboozled by the change up two down
facing stewart now to two
he got him strike three
lucas strikes out three in the inning
and walks off with a doughnut still
there four nothing socks over the tigers
bottom of the fourth inning tim at the
top of the major league baseball lead of
multiple run-scoring games
tim hits a dart deep left field he
watches it fly this is good
the tigers have felt this wrath before
and cook up the pasta it's five nothing
his sixth home run he's driven in nine
this is a slider and see tim hits
breaking balls that are close to the
zone very well
lucas
threw five three and two to jacoby jones
oh he got him strike three locked him up
with a change lucas today has cooled off
a very hot hitter in jonathan scope and
lucas
cuts him down
the pained expression and the murmur
and for the eighth time in his career
ten plus strikeouts
oh change up just feathery touch for
strike three
this is 11 of them one down stewart
oh yeah
12 strikeouts for lucas giolito
pretty good but one way or the other
this is going to be the last inning for
lucas you know he wants to strike out
bad here
three and two
the puppet show continues the answer was
yes he wanted to stay in 13 strikeouts
ties a career high two base runners to
get jose one more shot one two
tagged to center field on a line and
down
rolling all the way to the wall in fact
tas hall moncada follows him
two more
seven nothing
eli with a couple of hits
[Applause]
high fly ball left field from eloy
jimenez to the track and a wall and out
of here
eloy jimenez does take one up and out as
my partner said earlier it's nine
nothing jimmy cordero remains in goings
two down
or a pop-up
third base side johan is over and lloyd
makes a catch and joan gets out of the
way
as the sox do win on a barrel roll
to close out the series